I do occasionally worry about the
academic world,
or at least parts of the academic world
being really mired in what some friends
of mine and I tend to call the cult of
irrelevance.
This idea of wanting to work on topics
that are of great interest to you and
three of your friends and to people at
another university.
Um,
and I think this is an abdication of our
responsibility as intellectuals.
We should be grappling with really big
questions as much as we can and
questions that are of great importance,
right?
That's why society allows us to have
these very privileged positions as
intellectuals are college professors or
whatever.
And the way we should be paying society
back is by using that to try and make
the human condition better.
Now,
we're not all going to agree,
but that's okay because we're more
likely to collectively reach a wise
position if we all think hard and then
argue about it and do so in public
whenever possible.